[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
mit barbara hahlweg guten abend schön
dass sie dabei sind wie auch norbert
lehmann für den sport eine gute antwort
familie wir haben unter anderem diese
themen für sie
nun koordiniert und jeder für sich nach
und nach gibt es in den bundesländern
neue corona regeln in bayern gilt jetzt
3g am arbeitsplatz
rasen wird deutlich teurer ein neuer
bußgeldkatalog soll ab heute deutsche
straßen sicherer machen und
corona in der nationalmannschaft niklas
süle wird positiv getestet vier weitere
spieler müssen in quarantäne
corona belastet bei weitem nicht nur die
fußball nationalmannschaft wegen der
steigenden zahl von corona patienten
verschiebt die berliner charité ab heute
alle planbaren operationen und immer
mehr bundesländer verschaffen ihre
maßnahmen wegen täglich neue höchstwerte
laut robert koch institut steigt die
sieben tage inzidenz heute auf 213 7
besonders betroffen sind teile von
sachsen thüringen und vor allem von
bayern dort liegt die inzidenz in
einigen landkreisen bereits bei über 800
in ganz bayern gelten seit mitternacht
verschärfte maßnahmen petra neubauer
berichtet
andreas benz egger und sein unternehmen
in rosenheim machen schon länger vor was
nun bayernweit gilt 3g am arbeitsplatz
hier klappt es bislang gut dass sich die
mitarbeiter die nicht geimpft oder
chinesen sind zwei mal die woche testen
offen beantworten sie fragen die andreas
becker eigentlich nicht stellen dürfte
wir müssen sagen hilft ja nein müssen es
im prinzip auch speichern und dürfen uns
nicht das ist schon eine deutliche lücke
die wiederwahl der wirtschaft
ausgelassen wird auch in der freizeit
wird es eng für die ungeimpften denn
durch die bayernweite zweig regel haben
sie zu vielen veranstaltungen keinen
zutritt mehr ausnahme sind etwa der
friseur oder gaststätten hier kann auch
ein negativer pcr test vorgelegt werden
der chef der münchen klinik vermisst bei
alldem mir voraus schauen ja das gift
irgendwie würde mir vielleicht anderes
buch dann jetzt auch schon müsste man
all diese maßnahmen jetzt nicht machen
wir wissen schon seit wochen dass wir
wieder im exponentiellen wachstum sind
es ist auch nichts neues auch das haben
wir schon gelernt so jetzt immer wieder
genau da wo wir stehen der
ministerpräsident wird nicht müde fürs
impfen zu werben kündigt an die
impfzentren in bayern wieder
hochzufahren es gibt keine reihenfolge
kein einladungsmanagement mit termin
sondern wer kommt da wird geimpft
niemand wird zurückgewiesen das werben
und auch die strengen regeln scheinen zu
wirken in der oberpfalz haben sich vor
einer spontan eingerichteten im station
schlangen gebildet es wird gepostet aber
auch erst geimpft
andere lösung also wir haben dann wieder
doktoren und das will ja keiner mich nun
schützen vor der krankheit und roma die
anderen schützen die zeit drängt denn
die intensivstationen werden immer
voller das personal arbeitet längst am
limit und noch ist der höhepunkt der
vierten welle nicht erreicht
noch geld sie aber am 25 november soll
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite auslaufen die aktuelle
rechtsgrundlage für corona maßnahmen
gestern stellten spd grüne und fdp ihre
anschluss regeln vor prompt gab es
kritik christoph des tarif fasst
zusammen
von der schulschließung bis zur kontakt
beschränkung 20 monate lang durfte der
staat durchgreifen wegen der
epidemischen lage jetzt aber finden die
ampel parteien sollte sich möglichst
zurücknehmen und sie schlagen neue
regeln vor für die zeit von november bis
mitte märz
etwa die rückkehr zu kostenlosen tests
für alle gleichzeitig eine pflicht zu 3g
am arbeitsplatz aber
geschäfte zu schulen zu kultur dicht das
soll es nicht mehr geben im ganzen 1 44
seiten entwurf der immer noch ziemlich
tief ins private leben eingreift doch
die vierte welle rollt mit wucht
kommunen und sozialverbänden gehen die
vorschläge daher nicht weit genug wir
hätten gerne zweig flächendeckend im
freizeitbereich gehabt also für den
freizeitbereich nur noch die
zugangsmöglichkeit für geimpfte und für
genesene was uns einfach fehlt ist eine
flächendeckende tests nicht genau für
die einrichtungen wo menschen besonderen
schutz brauchen nämlich die
pflegeeinrichtungen auch in den
krankenhäusern schrillen die
alarmglocken etwa an der uniklinik in
dresden wo immer mehr corona intensiv
fälle immer mehr kräfte binden die
patienten die jetzt auch mit
krebserkrankungen mit mit schlaganfällen
die
verunfallten wir können diese patienten
nicht mehr nach den eigentlich gängigen
qualitätsstandards versorgen bislang
wenn bei den regeln nachjustiert werden
musste gab es die bund länder treffen
also am besten auch jetzt gemeinsam den
corona fahrplan für die wintermonate
abstecken fordern länderchefs aus der
union dazu bedarf es zeitnah eine
abstimmung zwischen bund und ländern am
besten noch diese woche
andere sind da zurückhaltender
die jüngsten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist noch
nicht lange her gerade drei wochen und
da haben wir genau diese themen intensiv
gesprochen wie also die korona welle
brechen wer gibt den weg vor die fragen
sind klar die antworten noch offen tja
wer gibt den weg vor sach attacke ist
wollen wir die leiterin unserer rechts
redaktion sarah was ändert sich mit dem
neuen gesetz was bleibt gleich was
bleibt ist das weiterhin die länder
selbst entscheiden welche kroner maße
innerhalb ihrer landesgrenzen gelten
aber aktuell kann die engländer aus
einem großen maßnahmenkatalog 18 an der
zahl die der bund vorgibt auswählen und
genau diesen großen maßnahmenkatalog der
soll zusammengeschrumpft und eingedampft
werden auf nur noch sechs mögliche
maßnahmen die länder dann ergreifen
können um auf das virus zu reagieren was
bleibt es zum beispiel masken pflicht
oder die möglichkeit 2g 3g
vorzuschreiben wäre es nicht viel klarer
die epidemische notlage einfach über den
winter hinaus zu verlängern ganz klar ja
wir haben ja gerade gesehen die
überforderung des gesundheitssystems
zeigt dass es sei verfassungsmäßig
überhaupt gar nicht angezeigt dass an
dieser rechtslage aktuell irgendetwas zu
ändern und es ist schon paradox dass auf
der einen seite wie eine lager haben
corona lage haben die sich zuspitzt die
verschärft und auf der anderen seite
maßnahmen entschärfen besonders deutlich
wird das an einer maßnahme von vielen
die gestrichen werden kontakt verboten
denn künftig nach der neuen rechtslage
wird es dann möglich sein dass man sich
im privaten rahmen ungeimpft ungetestet
mit beliebig vielen personen treffen
kann und natürlich sind diese kontakt
beschränkungen besonders tiefer eingriff
in meine grundrechte mir vorzuschreiben
mit wem ich mich in meinem privaten
bereich treffe ist ein tiefer eingriff
aber auch ein besonders wirkungsvoll
eingriff weil dieses virus verbreitet
sich ja nun mal über kontakte das heißt
solche treffen in privaten räumen in
ungeordneten ausmaß können besonders
gefährlich sein und auch einen treiber
der pandemie seien am donnerstag soll
der gesetzentwurf erstmals im bundestag
beraten werden vielen dank für diese
einschätzung und erläuterung seiner
attacke
das mainzer
pharmaunternehmen bayer und tec hat in
den ersten neun monaten dieses jahres
etwa 71 milliarden euro gewinn erzielt
das liegt vor allem am corona impfstoff
produziert mit dem us-partner pfizer von
dem erfolg profitiert auch die hoch
verschuldete stadt mainz die rekord
gewerbesteuer einnahmen bringen einen
milliardenüberschuss im haushalt
corona ist auch in dänemark wieder
großes thema die infektionszahlen
steigen stark ministerpräsidentin
fredriksen hat deshalb die rückkehr zu
3g regel vorgeschlagen damit wären
gastronomie und bestimmte
veranstaltungen wieder nur für geimpfte
genesene und negativ getestete zugelegt
nämlich das land hatte vor rund zwei
monaten sämtliche beschränkungen
aufgehoben
bei uns ist derzeit eine 3g regelung am
arbeitsplatz im gespräch in der zdf-
heute- app beantworten wir fragen zur
geplanten neuregelung und zeigen worauf
sich beschäftigte einstellen müssen
an der eu-außengrenze zwischen polen und
belarus spitzt sich die
flüchtlingssituation weiter zu beide
staaten ziehen im grenzgebiet soldaten
und polizeikräfte zusammen mehr als 3000
flüchtlinge harren in belarus in einem
waldstück aus nach einem geschlossenen
grenzübergang viele von ihnen wollen
durch polen nach deutschland
aus warschau berichtet eine brille
sie haben die nacht im freien verbracht
in zelten bei minustemperaturen haben
die hoffnung nicht aufgegeben doch noch
nach polen nach europa zu kommen und
weiter zu reisen nach deutschland
wir wollen nicht nach polen wir wollen
nach deutschland richtig deutschland
nicht polen
12.000 soldaten sichern die grenze nach
belarus truppenbesuch vom polnischen
ministerpräsidenten rasiejewski
journalisten sind nicht zugelassen
die bilder produziert die polnische
regierung war selbst
wer hätte noch vor eins zwei drei
monaten gedacht dass wir solch ein
handeln entgegen treten was hat den
charakter von lebenden schutzschilden
bei lukaschenkos regime zivilisten als
waffe benutzt in diesem hybriden krieg
eine neue perfide art der kriegsführung
auf die polen sich eingestellt hat
massiv hatte seine streitkräfte
verstärkt und in einer sicherheitszone
zusammengezogen was darin passiert auch
mit geflüchteten keiner weiß das genau
fotos zeigen menschen die im wald
campieren von polen zurück geschickt von
den bella russen nicht wieder ins land
gelassen leben im niemandsland ohne
winter kleidung ohne schuhe die eu mahnt
für uns ist es von entscheidender
bedeutung dass die polnischen behörden
mit dieser situation angemessen umgehen
dass sie wirksam auf diese bedrohung
durch das lukaschenko regime reagieren
und gleichzeitig humanitäre fragen und
die achtung der grundrechte beachten
tausende migranten in belarus an europas
außengrenzen
spielball mächtiger inter auch dass
lukaschenko regime weiß um die macht der
bilder
fragen wir unseren korrespondenten in
moskau christiansen was will der
belarussische präsident mit den
flüchtlingen erreichen
alexander lukaschenko will damit vor
allem erreichen dass die
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen belarus dass
die zurückgenommen werden die eu hatte
die sanktionen verhängt nach den
umstrittenen parlamentswahlen im letzten
jahr und dem massiven vorgehen des
lukaschenko regimes gegen die opposition
entgegen medien lukaschenko will jetzt
den druck auf europa erhöhen und es ist
ein ja kann man sagen erpressungsversuch
nach dem motto entweder ihr redet mit
mir und nehmen die sanktionen zurück
oder ich schicke euch tausende
flüchtlinge und das wird jetzt
ausgetragen auf dem rücken dieser
menschen wir haben zum beitrag gerade
hier sehen die an der grenze jetzt
gestrandet sind welche rolle spielt
moskau dabei
man kann davon ausgehen dass hier in
moskau alles besprochen wurde mit
belarus mit dem belarussischen präsident
mit alexander lukaschenko der austausch
ist da sehr sehr eng erst letzte woche
haben lukas schenk und putin miteinander
gesprochen in einer video-konferenz da
ging es um den um den unionsstaaten
zwischen belarus und russland der
geplant ist da gibt es immer wieder
gespräche und da hat putin noch einmal
demonstrativ lukaschenko den rücken
gestärkt und es gibt ja nicht mehr viele
die auf lukas schenkel noch einen wirken
können putin gehört sicherlich dazu er
könnte das machen aber er macht das
nicht er hat der moment kein interesse
daran stattdessen laufen hier im
staatsfernsehen jetzt auch die ganze
zeit schon die bilder der grenze und man
kann mal wieder ein bild zeichen von
einem europa im chaos und lukas schenkel
wenn der mit dem westen über kreuz liegt
das kann hier in moskau nur recht sein
live aus moskau christian seinem vielen
dank
heute ist er neunter november ein
historisches datum für deutschland ein
heller und ein dunkler tag sagt
bundespräsident steinmeier dafür stehen
drei daten
der fall der mauer und die große freude
am 9 november
barbarisch dagegen die
nationalsozialisten brennenden synagogen
und jüdische geschäfte nieder
1938 in der pogromnacht und auch das
heute die erinnerung an 1918 als der
grundstein für die demokratie gelegt
wurde aus berlin patricia wiedemeier
der neunten november er sei zu recht
kein feiertag zu widersprüchlich zu
ambivalent für den bundespräsidenten ein
tag zum nachdenken über unser land
1918 und 1989 in diesen beiden jahren
waren es freuden tage nach dem ersten
weltkrieg brachte er deutschland
republik und demokratie
1989 fiel die mauer das ende der ddr war
besiegelt lehren aus der vergangenheit
demokratie zu verteidigen heißt heute
auch unseren parlamentarismus
abzustauben
jetzt müssen wir gemeinsam neues
vertrauen wecken die erinnerung an den
mauerfall am 9 november 89 ist ein
signal in die welt dass
menschen für die zukunft mut machen kann
diktator ist überwindbar
dies ist das hoffnungszeichen aus
deutschland nach pedros china oder kuba
aber der neunten november steht auch für
die reichspogromnacht des jahres 1938
für antisemitismus hass und hetze
bewegen die schilderungen der
holocaust-überlebenden margot
friedländer aus diesen tagen wir wussten
das ist
der anfang vom viel schlimmeren was noch
kommen wird
neunter november
ist ein ambivalenter tag ein heller und
ein dunkler tag er macht uns herzklopfen
und
treibt uns eben ging es eben auch so
tränen in die augen
meinen augen ist er neunter november der
deutsche tag schlechthin der neunte
november ein tag der für die verbrechen
der deutschen ebenso steht wie für das
ringen um freiheit und demokratie
ganz anderes thema jetzt ab heute geht
der neue bußgeldkatalog
verkehrsdelikte werden deutlich teurer
zu schnelles fahren etwa oder fall
sprachen und eine ganze menge mehr
elisabeth schmidt mit einem überblick
nienburg in niedersachsen neun uhr
berufsverkehr gleich am ersten tag des
neuen bußgeldkatalogs kontrolliert die
polizei hier mit der laserpistole
59 km/h das beteuert denn wer innerorts
16 bis 20 kilometer pro stunde zu
schnell fährt und erwischt wird zahlt
statt bislang 35 jetzt 70
begeistert muss eigentlich zur arbeit
hat es eigentlich ziemlich eilig aber
das sind halt dieses sondern aus geben
die man hört der neue bußgeldkatalog
soll vor allem sie besser schützen
radfahrer und fußgänger unerlaubtes
parken auf geh und radwegen oder halten
in zweiter reihe kostet statt 25 jetzt
bis zu 110 euro
unberechtigtes parken auf plätzen für
elektro- oder carsharing autos 55 euro
richtig teuer kann es für alle werden
die keine rettungsgasse bilden oder
diese blockieren 200 bis 320 euro plus
ein monat fahrverbot
ich finde das hätten wir noch wesentlich
teurer machen könnten eine andere
maßnahme kommt einfach bei den bürgern
nicht an sonst würden auch nicht so
viele fahrradunfälle passieren ich meine
greifen uns schon überall in die tasche
und immer tiefer zwei euro in liter
benzin neulich auf rügen was bringen
immer höhere geldbußen
verkehrspsychologen befürchten der
abschreckt wird nicht lange an das ist
vielleicht also für den anfangs so dann
wird man halt eben in der regel also
sich an den entsprechenden kosten
gewöhnen und diese dann eben auch tagen
auch wenn es viel geld ist strafen sind
dass eine gesunde menschenverstand dass
andere fazit der polizei heute in
nienburg die meisten raser zeigten sich
immerhin einsichtig
weil sie sich mutig für andere
eingesetzt haben dafür wurden soeben
zwei männer und eine junge frau in
berlin ausgezeichnet mit dem preis
gemeinsam gegen das verbrechen der zdf
sendung aktenzeichen xy ungelöst
innenminister seehofer überreichte die
mit jeweils 10.000 euro dotierte
auszeichnung die preisträgerin war 16
jahre alt als sie im hessischen
volkmarsen ein amokfahrer amokfahrer in
den karnevalsumzug raste sie hinderte
den täter an der weiterfahrt
hut ab und jetzt zum neuen corona fall
im dfb-team genau niklas süle obwohl
doppelt geimpft ist positiv getestet
worden der abwehrspieler und vier
weitere nationalspieler mit denen der
kontakt hatte haben das dfb quartier in
wolfsburg verlassen bundestrainer flick
hat bereits für das wm quali spiel am
donnerstag nachnominiert nachdem das
vormittagstraining abgesagt wurde setzte
flick am abend doch noch eine einheit an
volland sowie die wolfsburger barcoo und
arnold ersetzen die abgereisten spieler
durch den wirbel um den positiv
getesteten süle wird das team erneut von
der pandemie eingeholt das muss man
jetzt so akzeptieren und auch damit
umgehen das machen wir auch in genua
weiter in verantwortungsvoll mit um auf
anweisung des gesundheitsamtes mussten
auch gabri musealer adeyemi und kimmig
vom team isoliert werden weil sie als
kontaktperson 1 eingestuft wurden und
sich nun alle in quarantäne befinden die
länge der quarantäne das kann ich ihnen
letztlich nicht beantworten das ist in
der hand des lokalen gesundheitsamtes
das hängt auch davon ab ob beschwerden
auftreten das hängt davon ab wie
eventuelle folge tests ausfallen die
vorbereitung auf das spiel erheblich
gestört doch die begegnung am donnerstag
soll laut dfb nicht in gefahr seien
1,3 milliarden euro schulden in der
spanischen liga nur mittelmaß in der
champions league droht das aus jetzt ist
er der hoffnungsträger in barcelona der
neue trainer schaaf ein anderes
es war keine herkömmliche
trainerverpflichtung ja wie das ist
emotion pur für barca fans 10.000
huldigten dem mann der hier 17 jahre
lang spieler war mit barcelona vier mal
die champions league gewann zudem welt
und europameister wurde
das wichtigste ist zu gewinnen von jetzt
an müssen wir hart arbeiten damit wir
resultate sehen barca ist
bewiesenermaßen gerade nicht auf dem
höhepunkt seiner historie aber wir sind
eine einheit damals rund durch wird
nötig sein in der champions league gegen
bayern war die katalanische misere
offensichtlich 0 zu 3 ohne treffer ohne
esprit das soll ja wie nun ändern eine
herkulesaufgabe
das war es auch schon von spot
dankeschön quer spätherbst zeigt sich
weiter mit nebel und sonne wer was
bekommt erklärt gleich katja horneffer
das heute journal um viertel vor zehn
mit marietta slomka wir wünschen ihnen
noch einen unbeschwerten abend und
lounges bis morgen wenn sie werden
[Musik]
guten abend heute strahlte die sonne vom
blauen himmel selten mussten sich mein
liebl felder lösen die hier zum beispiel
im alpenvorland oder auch am oberrhein
bis mittag waren die nebelfelder dann
aber auch hier an main und mosel weg und
auch die wolkenfelder im nordosten lösen
sich mehr und mehr auch nur nordwesten
da gab es die dichteren wolken die
brachten auch ein bisschen regen mit und
die werden uns da auch heute nacht noch
beschäftigen da bleibt es einfach
bedeckt sonst aber ist der himmel oft
klar und es bildet sich wieder nebel
unter den dichteren wolken in nordwest
und auch an der ostsee bleibt die nacht
mit mit 10 bis 7 grad sonst aber sinken
die werte auf plus 2 bis minus 4 grad am
boden wird es frostig und da kann es
örtlich auch mal glatt sein morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen dann um 10
grad im dauer grau bleibt dagegen bei 5
grad deutlich kälter mit leichter föhn
unterstützung am alpenrand werden aber
sogar 14 grad erreicht auch morgen im
nordwesten dichtere wolken und dann kann
es ja an der schlei oder auch auf sylt
ein bisschen regnen zwischen den aus
riesigen insel unter lübecker bucht und
die wolken ihr die ich sonst aber ziehen
über norddeutschland häufig zu
schleierwolken entdeckt in
süddeutschland muss ich erstmal nebel
auflösen das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr ganz so gut klappen wie noch heute
und ganz ähnlich geht es in den nächsten
tagen auch weiter guten abend